an occupying force now in total control
of a ukrainian city
russian military vehicles rumble through
the neighborhoods its troops patrol the
deserted streets
this is the black sea port of kersen the
first ukrainian city to fall to the
russians
i'm here with my grandmother now and um
we have enough food for couple weeks so
we try not to leave because it's very
dangerous right now and our government
asked us to sit at home
the russian bombardment has been
unrelenting moscow says
it's only targeting strategic military
sites
but this is mario paul now
a south eastern city that has seen some
of the fiercest fighting and remains
surrounded on all sides by the russian
army
a week into the war and ukraine's
president remains as defiant now
as he did when his country was attacked
i don't even know exactly two years ago
the first case of kovit was recorded in
ukraine the first weeks of fighting were
extremely difficult but we were united
and therefore strong and therefore we
withstood exactly a week ago ukraine was
attacked by another virus another
disease one week ago at 4 am russia
invaded our independent ukraine our land
some aid is reaching ukraine
these are vital medical supplies leaving
stansted airport
with a number of injured and displaced
rising by the hour
it is desperately needed
the british foreign secretary visiting
allies in lithuania has pledged more
than just medical aid we're helping
ukraine defend itself
our defensive weapons from the united
kingdom are now being used to stop
russian tracks
moscow says it is prepared to talk but
at the same time there is no let up in
its onslaught
sky news has verified this video to an
oil depot on the outskirts of cherniv in
northern ukraine
i think that this hysteria will end
and our partners will
will settle down calm down after a while
and
and we will sit down to negotiate but
only on one
absolute condition that it has to be
equal
positions it will equal parties
negotiating
many ukrainians are defending their land
however they can
these people have set up a crude
roadblock around the ernadar nuclear
power plant
as they try to stop or at least store
the russian advance
while those who have stayed behind do
what they can
to defend their lives and their property
others continue to pour out of the
country
[Applause]
more than a million have now been forced
to flee the conflict
and they
will not be the last ashish joshi sky
news